[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
yeah
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them [__]
[Music]
ass [__]
pretty simple pretty straight forward
pretty straightforward I mean where's
the LIE really
if we're gonna be honest where's the
[__] lie
[__] ass [__] it all boils down to
three words yesterday that absolutely
destroyed
the Republican party's attempt
to act like the government Joe baden's
Joe Biden's government
and the Democrats somehow are using
government to weaponize and silence
conservatives quote unquote they're not
conservatives they're [__] Nazis
and we find out in the hearing yesterday
this is beautiful this really is
beautiful they have hour long hours long
hearings
to try to prove
that the United States government was
intentionally colluding with Twitter
before Elon bought it because of the
Twitter files that Elon and Matt taibi
had dropped
that somehow the government
was making sure to silence Republican
voices on Twitter now you had Lauren
bobert Marjorie Taylor green freaking
out about Haller counts her Shadow band
I mean
listen let's back up a bit spec let's
back up a bit let's go back to last year
okay let's go back to last year in the
summer
before the 2022 midterms
foreign let's remember
what we were saying here on the Tony
Michaels podcast which was that
if we let
these fascist pieces of [__]
take control
of Our House of Representatives
that they will do nothing but waste our
money and our time
with [__] lies absolute
[__] lies
that that that is what that
is what we said
now let's go forward a bit
we're after the 2022 midterms it was
unclear whether Republicans would or
wouldn't have a majority enough to to
take the house away from the Democrats
turned out there was just a handful
a little bit further well Kevin McCarthy
took 15 votes to become speaker
but he traded away his speakership
for this hearing yesterday this is one
of the things he traded away
Kevin McCarthy is the Speaker of the
House
the speaker of the house has the ability
not to let these [__] chuckleheads
continue to try to prosecute absolute
[__] bold-faced lies and delusions
when they know that's what they are
he has that ability he he can do that if
he was a real speaker but he's not he's
not a real speaker
he's a [__] coward
and he's a [__] ass [__] Kevin
McCarthy Jim Jordan [__] ass [__]
Comer [__] ass [__] Lauren bobert
[__] ass [__]
Marjorie Taylor green Matt Getz
Nancy mace [__] ass [__]
that's what they are
that's the truth
they just can't handle it
and we've got a long ways to go folks
like it's [__] February 9th
2023 like we got a ways to go here
and these [__] are already
slipping and falling in their own pile
of [__]
I'm excited I'm [__] excited I don't
know why why anyone would be anything
but excited about what happened
yesterday
are they making a mockery of our
government yes have they had when
haven't they been in the last [__] 15
years really made a mockery of our
[__] government Mitch McConnell
listen to me listen to me when I tell
you this Mitch McConnell
in 2010 said in a camera our number one
objective in the Senate is to make sure
Barack Obama is a one-term president I
don't know if you remember what 2008 9
and 10 11 and 12 were like
for the economy and the American people
but really making sure that the entire
Senate and the majority in the Senate
own is only [__] of authority was to
make sure Barack Obama wasn't going to
become president which is not
which is not
the job of the legislative branch by the
way that's the American people's job
it's our job we vote those [__]
in
the president that is
whoever he or she may be
it's our [__] job not Mitch
McConnell's job folks they're a joke
they're a [__] joke
and they're all all the way back to 2010
when Mitch McConnell's number one goal
was to get rid of the black guy oh we'll
get rid of that black guy for you that's
our number one goal forget about the
economy forget about people losing their
houses and their well-being and their
jobs and their living forget about the
economic future of your children we
can't have that black dude as a
president of the United States
and we're surprised we're supposed to be
surprised that that little whiny [__]
Donald Trump
got his undies so much in a [__]
bundle his diaper in a wad
because Chrissy Teigen tweeted at him
after he [__] disparaged her on
Twitter and called him a [__] ass [__]
not only that so such a [__]
snowflake so [__] cowardly such a
goddamn [__] that you had to use the
government White House our White House
staff and our government to call Twitter
and to demand that they take it down get
the [__] out of here with this nonsense
about Hunter Biden and his [__]
laptop and his [__] pictures and him
doing blow get the [__] out of here with
this [__] this Twitter file [__]
Matt taibi you are done friend you are
done your entire reputation is smoked
the idea the idea that somehow somehow
these Twitter files exposed the fact
that government
was somehow colluding and demanding the
private companies censor people
and it's and it's right-wing Nazis that
they were trying to censor
using the big arm of the government when
it was them them it's always projection
always every [__] time every
[__] time don't ever doubt it
that's why I'm telling I'm telling you
I'm telling you again and again and over
and over again Donald Trump will be
their nominee
he's gonna be it
no [__] way are they gonna be able to
pick someone else they can't
they can't they won't because they're
[__] [__] ass [__]
every [__] last one of them she was
right she was [__] right oh might
break terms of service I don't give a
[__] she was right
free speech is a [__] ain't it
and the truth is a [__] it is a
sumbitch
when you tell the truth
especially when you tell it in a way
that gets people's attention
and to think to think think about this
for a second can you imagine if our
white house right now the Biden White
House [__] [__] had to call Twitter
every time they called Joe Biden a name
can you even fight that is so [__]
laughable
to imagine that the White House would
have every single time they called Joe
Biden a mean name on Twitter that those
[__] have to call Twitter call
Elon get Elon on the goddamn phone to
make sure he takes down that mean tweet
about Joe Buck get the [__] out of here
I I almost bet you a hundred dollars
that yesterday
when they watch this play out in this
Committee hearing
when they get to the part about how the
actual Trump government the Trump
Administration the Trump White House was
the ones trying to bully private
companies
not only that not only that we found out
yesterday that Twitter changed its terms
of service for that [__]
change their terms of service
because he's such a [__] petulant
child
have you ever been in a grocery store
and I and I know this is a kind of a
Trope have you ever been in a grocery
store
and you have
you have the parents
of children that are acting up
and they're doing their best like they
really are trying like they're trying
their hardest
to to whatever reason maybe they had a
lot of sugar maybe the kids had a bad
day maybe they're [__] tired and
haven't eaten yet they're hangry right
these kids are [__] hangry
and the parents are doing their best
trying to keep them in line trying to
keep them in control
doing the best they can
and you look at them and if you're a
parent you go oh man I remember what
that was like
that's a situation we're in right we
have to put up with these [__] these
petulant children who are hangry for
Hunter Biden's laptop
and to have all their feely feels right
you know even though it's not based in
any fact make sure that their beliefs
are backed up even if by lies
and then there's the parent
with the one [__] you know what I'm
you know what I'm saying you know what
the [__] I'm saying there's the parent
with the one [__]
run around knocking [__] over stomping
on cereal boxes throwing meat out of the
cooler
eating [__] putting it back on the Shelf
and the parents just like oh yeah this
is great you're hilarious oh man
I love my kid encouraging him that's the
Republican Party
the only reason why they had a Committee
hearing yesterday in the first place is
because the orange Mussolini Jesus told
them to okay this this is this was not
an exercise in brilliance
this was an exercise in buffoonery so
that is how I know for sure
the only way that this hearing happened
yesterday and they fell flat on their
[__] face is because of trump
it's not difficult to understand these
things it's easy these people are
predictably unpredictable
and we need more of it I know it feels
like oh my God Tony they're making a
mockery of our government yeah but
listen this is this is this is the
exercise that we have to do in democracy
this is it folks this is what you got
you [__] around you find out you [__]
around and don't protect your democracy
in the correct way and I'm not just
talking about 20 22 or 2020 or 2016.
I'm talking about all the way back when
Mitch McConnell said our number one goal
is to get rid of the black guy because
white people don't like the black guy
well the white people that vote for us
don't like the black guy
that's what Mitch McConnell was saying
I mean he stopped short of the n-word no
[__] I don't know if you've seen that
clip but it's true
[__] him and [__] anyone who says any
different oh well it was about policy no
it wasn't no it wasn't
no it wasn't
thank you
because Barack Obama was black
and he had a funny name oh scary name
scary name
that's why terrified of him terrified
of Barack Obama they were
for those reasons and those reasons
alone they didn't have to go past that
they didn't have to get into policy get
the [__] out of here with that nonsense
all the way back
all the way back to when Mitch McConnell
said that
they've been making a mockery of our
government we've been doing this
exercise of buffoonery
and it's taken till now it's taken till
now for them to be exposed real and raw
that they're [__] frauds they're
[__] coward snowflakes they're [__]
ass [__]
I don't know what to tell you I don't
know what to do besides let them do it
and expose them
we do it here every day and we we don't
we don't have we don't have the
capability
of a of a house Committee hearing
to make to make good on exposing these
[__] idiots these Maga morons okay
we have to do it in a different way we
have to be a little more creative we
have to pull clips
from where they're getting these ideas
from
the [__] disease the rot that is
rotting their brains the delusion
that has taken over their ideology
we have to find that in little pockets
and show you why they're saying and
doing the [__] they're doing but
yesterday was a Master Class A Master
Class
and it's not difficult these things
aren't difficult with these [__]
chuckleheads because they don't have any
shame at all and they're not they don't
care about lying they don't care about
being selfish
because most of the people that were
sitting in that Committee hearing
yesterday
on the Republican side we're there for
selfish reasons
not for the American people
and the Democrats the only reason why
they fought is because it's a waste of
America's time of [__] waste
to waste your day away
on
on [__] lies
lies
and delusion
that somehow it was more important
that Hunter Biden's [__] be viewable on
Twitter then the actual White House at
that time
telling Twitter what they were were and
weren't gonna do and changing your terms
of service
for one one [__] user on the entire
site
because he's a [__] ass [__]
what do you want from me
I mean that that that three-word phrase
pretty much sums up yesterday
what the result of the hearing was and
we're gonna we're gonna watch it today
we're gonna watch it today because this
is super important I know you're like
Jesus Christ are you kidding me they're
gonna talk about this [__] I mean in the
comments right now I'm sure there's a
bunch of dumb [__]
a bunch of haters talking about how oh
yeah they slammed up the Democrats
yesterday what about this and what about
that well what about this Tony
let's see
um
oh yeah see here you go Don says the
only thing Democrats are able to get out
was that Trump asked one tweet be
removed no dumb [__] you weren't
listening you're not listening Don clean
clean the Maga [__] out of your ears
buddy cleaning out of your [__] ears
and hear me you're here every day surely
you're [__] listening you delusional
piece of [__]
clean your ears out they changed the
terms of service because Trump is a
[__] he's a [__] he's a snowflake
Everything You Accuse Democrats and
Liberals are being that's who he is hook
mind Sinker that's who the [__] he is
Don
and that's who you are that's the point
that's the point that's the real point
is that's who you are you are you are so
you are
you are so insufficient
you you must have had a heart something
happened something must have happened
where you just don't feel fulfilled
and you don't feel like you contributed
enough to this country that this country
turned its back on you because of your
problems
not because of ours because of yours
and because you're such a petulant
little child it's not surprising that
you absolutely will go to the end of the
Earth To Worship another petulant child
and be a member of the cult
and until you really just wake up and
realize that you [__] up and you've
been doing this stupid thing on the
internet on Facebook
until you do that you're not gonna be
okay
it's gonna come back and smack you in
the face every [__] time every
single time
and here here he goes I could I
contributed more than you could ever
wish for yeah okay great great
projection there and see what I'm
talking about do you see what I'm
talking about yet Don do you see what
I'm talking about
do you see do you see you old [__]
white nut sack I know that's what you
are
I know you're you're a [__] old ass
racist your daddy was a racist your
grandpappy was a racist why not you be a
racist
and Donald Trump hates him hates him
some Obama
it's what it is just admit it man
all I can do is Bully good
good
I'm just trying to set you straight I'm
just trying to give you why why you're
in the situation that you're in and
yesterday
the Republicans in the house are
Representatives absolutely made fools
out of themselves
fools destroyed their entire [__]
destroyed their entire narrative
yesterday it destroyed it this idea this
idea that liberals and Democrats are
weaponizing government to come after you
and to come after private companies got
destroyed yesterday and the reason why
is because that's not what they're doing
they're not doing that at all they're
being good stewards in democracy in
general
they're trying to set policy
to make sure it benefits all people in
America
for equity and equality I know these
these [__] words don't mean much to
you
and even if they do even if you know the
definitions you hate the definitions to
these words that's why you hate the word
Liberty that's why you hate the word
liberal that's why you hate the word
democracy I'm almost bet Don that you've
said in the last week three four times
at least we're not a democracy we're a
republic
almost bet bet
and again if you think me telling you
the truth in a real and raw way
coming at you
with a sense of I don't know logic
rational thought
is bullying well you you are a dumb
[__] and I'm sorry I'm sorry
that I gotta Point these things out
but until you [__] open your
eyes open your ears and realize you're
the ones being duped
you're being duped you're being duped
and believing that something's happening
that the people your supporter is
actually doing I don't know if you went
and looked at like all the [__] all
the people that have been arrested all
the politicians that have been arrested
for diddling kids they're not Democrats
they're [__] Republicans dude
I don't know if you went and looked at
all the [__] Epstein people
your guy is one of them Epstein would
car over
his his [__] his
those [__] young girls that he would
rape and molest
he would take him over to Mar-A-Lago in
a private Vehicle Buddy
I don't know if you know that [__] or
not
and and and the whole Hunter Biden thing
where he's [__] He's coked up on Blow
yes so what you ever watch one just one
[__] video of Don Jr's buddy
people really do need to pluck your head
out of your ass
and yesterday there's no better example
of what of why you need to do that
why you need to do that
and if you would just do that we could
move forward like we could move on past
this [__] this timeline is stupid
where the only thing that matters the
only thing that matters is that you hold
that [__] ass [__]
Donald Trump on high
and the reason why is because he
represents
the entirety
of the Cults insufficiencies
your ineffectiveness
you're lost
we get it we know we don't have Cults
work
this isn't new Cults aren't new we know
and we know how it goes
but yesterday was a master class and
we're going to watch it here on the Tony
Michaels podcast you can damn well
better bet that Don so stay tuned buddy
I'm gonna show you all the [__] that
your Fox News oan and Newsmax won't show
you all the [__] that ain't in your
[__] feed
I'm gonna show you oh she see here he
goes okay Clinton was at Epstein's
wedding dude dude dude if that's such so
egregious I know you're doing the what
about ISM thing I get it
go go search images
of Donald Trump and Jeffrey Epstein
you're [__] dude your [__] dude
was like Justine Maxwell oh yeah I hope
she oh I hope she's I hope she's
wonderful couldn't say ill will a batter
man there's a reason buddy there's a
[__] reason and you're missing it and
you're missing it because you're part of
the cult you're delusional you're
absolutely mind [__] you've been
brainwashed it's okay it's all right
we're here for you man you're here every
day keep coming man maybe maybe one of
these days something will click and
you're [__] rotted racist brain will
realize
that maybe you were wrong because you
can be wrong humans are wrong all the
[__] time oh they're wrong you know
you know the other thing that humans can
do is admit that they're wrong
that's what humans can do they can admit
that they're wrong I mean not
not scumbag Republicans in general I
mean Jesus Christ have you ever met
George Santos he should be your [__]
hero
heed this advice
pluck your head out of your ass open
your [__] ears and your eyes
and realize that you
have been duped by these people you are
being tricked by them
you are
and that's what they want
it's the whole point this is the whole
point of yesterday's thing about 100
miles left to happen to Twitter files
and
Liberals are using the government to
weaponize to to put people in prison
on and on and on it goes but the
delusional laptop talk
on and on it goes
and I'll show you a clip from Katie
Porter one of your favorites Don I'll
show you a clip from Katie Porter when
she explains that listen the link that
you're talking about that they took down
it wasn't even that [__] hearing
lasted longer than the link was down
that you couldn't share
you're just not listening you're not
listening Don you're not listening
it's okay one of these days you'll you
will you will everybody I'm glad to have
you here glad to have you here on a
Thursday February 9th 2023 I can't wait
to get into the [__] list Roundup these
[__] Clips are awesome [__]
fantastic again they're a master class
on how to handle these [__] lies and
their [__]
and again I hope they continue this
Twitter file thing
let's do that hell yeah I hope they have
15 more hearings on this stupid [__]
and they absolutely destroy
their narrative and their messaging
about it
because that's our job now is to go out
into the country and get people to
realize that all the [__] they said in
2022 to try to get elected we're good
we're good we're gonna go after the
Democrats because you're after you
when they're not
now it's your chance now is your time
to go and spread the word
tell the [__] country
with our messaging with our narrative
with the truth
and show people that it is all
projection from Trump and the America
the real America First Nazis
because that's what they are that's what
they've always been
and they'll continue to be that way
you just need to expose them everyone
stick around we'll be back with the
shitless Roundup we got to get through
these clips there's a ton of them right
after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're
[Music]
to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show thanks for
sticking around
oh done
I don't apologize
no sure don't [__]
what do you want from me
[Laughter]
you're a meanie head yeah
Don's a [__] ass [__] that's just
that's just the way it is report me Don
get me banned oh my God call call the
Trump White House Down at Mar-A-Lago
call them down there maybe you'll use
the shadow government that's being run
by the military JFK Jr and Michael
Jackson and Donald Trump himself to make
sure to shut me up censor me cancel me
oh just make sure that they they silence
my boy get the [__] out of here no one's
trying to silence anyone no one's ever
been silenced no one's ever been
canceled it's all [__] in the first
place all of it all of it
you don't believe me
go go look and see that Bill Cosby and
Louis C.K is on tour
just go look
oh look that [__] up
get the [__] out of here canceled
these [__] snowflakes
bitching because their their accounts
were Shadow banned oh we were Shadow but
get the [__] out here that's because
you're a scumbag and you're spreadering
out but spreading around misinformation
and a clear attempt to lie to people
and Twitter is a private company
rather Elon owned it or the shareholders
owned it they're a private company
their private Media company they did not
have to allow you to do that on their
website see that's not how freedom of
speech works and again this is the thing
that we have to [__] do this is the
thing that we have to [__] do
continually is to explain to these [__]
eaters what the [__] first amendment
is I I cannot I can't
how many I can't decide if it's going to
be a million
maybe 5.1 billion like the same amount
of money the same number that was given
to an elementary school in Illinois at
Marjorie Taylor Green Dot 5.1 billion
we're probably gonna have to say it a
lot and continue to say it a lot look
the First Amendment does not apply to
the people on Twitter's platform it
applies to Twitter on their property you
dumb [__]
that's how
freedom of speech works
Twitter has the right the first
amendment protecting it
to make sure that it does not have to
let anyone and everyone just [__]
write whatever they want
on their website it's theirs they own it
now Elon owns it and of course he'll let
anyone write anything oh he uh
especially Nazis now if anyone's writing
anything about him now not so much
not so much he'll cancel them he'll make
sure to silence their voice and he can
he can remember what remember when they
were uh they were he was shutting down
accounts for journalists do you remember
this and Aaron Rupert was one of them we
use a lot of Aaron's Clips here on the
Tony Michaels podcast thank you Aaron
for all the hard work you do by the way
but they shut his account down and
everyone was so pissed off and I said
look he can do it he can kick me he
could kick Aaron he could kick whoever
the [__] he wants off his website he can
do it
he owns it I don't own Twitter I don't
own it I actually have an account on
Twitter that I agree to is certain terms
and service
and he can kick me off anytime he
[__] wants
that's that that's how it works I know
that [__] I got okay we we gotta strike
against this on YouTube because I guess
I called white people crackers which I'm
sure I'll get [__] dinged here on
this episode they'll take it down and
give me a strike and I won't be able to
[__] stream because I call white
people crackers get the [__] out of here
you snowflake little [__] you are
crackers
and then YouTube yesterday they didn't
give us a strike but they took down an
entire two-hour episode because I played
on silent I played the Grammys the the
video of Sam Smith dressed in a devil
costume oh my God they took down that
episode what the [__] you want me to do
I can't do anything about I mean I can
[__] I can yell and scream at YouTube
maybe I could get Joe Biden to call
YouTube for me Don
I can't I can't do [__] about it and am
I am I upset about it why I mean not so
much I mean I guess you know there's an
episode that you guys can't watch and I
think what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go
put some section somewhere aband
episodes on patreon because then they
can't [__] with me if I go put it out
and I gate it to where only only people
on patreon can see and I'm gonna open it
up to all the tears everyone in all the
tiers can have access no matter if you
pay 5 10 20 50 100 what whatever tier
you're in you can see the Band episodes
because I think there's about four of
them I believe
that YouTube has banned and they they
deleted them they took my web they took
my episodes down now Apple Spotify
Google
all the other Google which is funny
Google podcast has not taken those
episodes down but they took them down
off their [__] YouTube uh you know
Google owns YouTube
you make it make sense I don't I'm not
saying it makes sense or not it's their
decision I'm posting [__] on their
website
I'm at their whim it's not my website I
don't own it
so I I have to not violate their terms
of service because it's their freedom of
speech when they own the website if you
want to go on a website Jim Jordan
Lauren bobert Marjorie Taylor green
Donald Trump like Donald Trump can't get
kicked off fraud social
he can't get kicked off fraud social he
can say anything he [__] wants he can
spread any information that he wants
over on Broad Social
and have no repercussions
and the reason why is because he owns it
well sort of
you know through money laundering
schemes specs and you know other [__]
federal financial crimes that he's
committed to
set up fraud social so he doesn't get
banned
[Laughter]
but yeah Jesus Christ we've seen last
week the Facebook
decided
that they'd let him back on
because it was their decision it's their
speech it's their property again I'll
give you uh [__] example and it's the
example I always use a lot of people
hate Walmart for a lot of good reasons
some people like Walmart really honestly
a lot of people hate that [__] place
even people who shop there frequently
hate that [__] place
there's a lot of reasons to hate Walmart
I mean a lot
there's some good things about Walmart
I'm not gonna lie some good things
there's a lot of things to hate here's
the here's the problem you cannot you
cannot
go
and spray paint on the side of Walmart's
building [__] Walmart I mean you could
you could you would probably be
criminally charged with
property damage
more than likely
now you can however stand off their
property unlike a public sidewalk where
their property ends and you can hold a
really big [__] sign that says [__]
Walmart
you can do that
because you're not on their property you
can't stand in their doorway you know
Walmart super Walmarts you go in the one
doors and then there's the other doors
you know it's like
the the foyer it is right before you get
to the the the the little old lady with
the carts you know she's like ah you
want a buggy right that yeah right
before you get to her you can't stand in
there next to the [__] vending
machines and the the claw toy machines
with a big sign that says [__] Walmart
you can't stand in there
you can't do that I mean you could for a
certain period of time until I get the
[__] out of here you can't do that here
we don't want you standing in our foyer
with your big ass [__] Walmart sign they
will kick you out
it's the same [__] things dummies you
cannot you cannot go against a website's
terms and service no matter no matter
how strict
or how loose their terms of service is
they have the ability to kick you off
Jim Jordan Lauren bobert they have the
right to Shadow ban you Lauren bobert
they have that right they can do
whatever they [__] want with your
account because it's not your account
it's your handle on their website where
you post your little [__] bigotry
most people you know want to post cat
pictures or titty Tuesday pictures or
you know that sort of thing maybe talk
about the game [__] like that Lauren
bobert Margaret Taylor green Jim Jordan
Donald Trump just lies they don't want
to lies they just want [__] lies
that's that's on brand it's on brand for
them it's on brand for them we're gonna
do this because I got to get to this
footage uh Gabe Sanchez is going to be
joining us very soon so let's do this
let's go to the [__] list Roundup where
we round up all the Tweety tweets and
trendy Trends I got all this these clips
from this um hearing yesterday
uh to show you so let's start the
countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Tony Michaels
podcast we've reached the part of the
show where we round up all the Tweety
tweets and trends of the day on elon's
Twitter
that's why I called elon's Twitter now
because he could remove me if he wanted
to all you all you first amendment
idiots out there it is not my first
amendment the post would now I get away
with a lot of [__] over on Twitter I'm
not sure why
I have no idea I'm not saying it has to
do with me being a male and white but
that probably has something to do with
it I would just say it's probably you
know white privilege kicking in there
I'd say that's probably what it is
that's why they don't [__] with me
that's why I say crazy [__] and the
crazy [__] I say is to try to direct in
a way that would tear down that white
privilege you God damn right
you got to use it to destroy it I mean
that's what we have to do in this
country
so what we got to do but you know who
who would think that equity and equality
is a good idea and Liberty is a good
idea I think um soon
um folks from the Midas touch channel
will be joining us so when they join us
and they get in the chat welcome them
here they're going to be redirected here
uh from a show that I think Ben
myzealous and Michael Cohen are doing
currently so they're going to be
redirected here so when they when they
pop in the chat here welcome them give
them a warm welcome to the Tony Michaels
podcast show them what the [__] fans
about in the chat folks maybe we'll get
them to subscribe get them to be regular
Watchers here at the Tony Michaels
podcast
um again
this shitless Roundup here let's let's
just get to it I guess I mean Jesus uh
there's so much tape to show where shall
we start
well we showed one yesterday where Jim
Jordan uh went on a five minute you know
tirade oh there he is look look who it
is look who it is Gabe Sanchez you still
haven't hung anything up in the
background no I haven't I'm waiting for
the weekend oh okay you got plans
I'm like still you know I'm still adding
little things to the desk
and then I'll put
all those things this is like a phase
type thing yeah like you can see like
there's two okay
I haven't put it out I just need a
minute to like think about the layout I
gotcha so come Monday
there will be stuff on the wall Let Me
Tell You Folks um I'm I'm kind of shoot
from the hip I don't know if you noticed
I'm shooting from them just say whatever
the [__] I want I really you know I I
there's a method to my madness obviously
you know but Gabe Sanchez is very very
very
detail-oriented yeah I mean actually I
think I've had an effect on you where
you don't pay as much attention and
you're like have to hyper you're like
look I gotta get this this idea that
that details aren't important I gotta
Focus because uh he's very
detail-oriented and and for good reason
that's one reason why I asked him to be
the executive producer here at the Tony
Michaels podcast because I'm not that I
do not pay attention to detail it is it
is very difficult uh years yeah of of
this detailed like because I can get I
can get very fixated on the small things
and to me I'm like oh do I know oh do I
know or even my partner I'll be like hey
what's you know what do you like this
versus this like I'll play a video and
then I'll ask her what she likes and she
goes what's the difference right and I
go well the difference is I say this one
word and she goes I didn't know I I
didn't know this and I don't know No
One's Gonna Know No One's Gonna know
he'll send me sometimes like um yeah he
does the thumbnails here for for the
show every morning that's how I wake him
up I'm like hey man what's um what's on
the thumbnail today and usually I kind
of have an idea or he has an idea and
then we go with it but every once in a
while he'll send me one and he's like oh
nope I'm like ready to push the button
to [__] create the show with this
thumbnail I think it looks great and
he's like nope I changed it I'm like
what the hell is the difference he's
like well the contrast and the lighting
and the hey I'm like okay yeah whatever
that's in the moment that I make it in
the moment that I make the thumbnail I'm
like oh this is good
and then like within two seconds after
sending like oh no I should make this
brighter so that so that it actually
pops a little more wow you got the crust
in your eyes you're still kind of like
rubbing it out you can't see you can't
see exactly what's going on but the the
best though the best I'll tell the
audience the best though is when he
misspells something oh my God you talk
about a total freak out I mean he's like
I noticed yeah I misspelled I misspelled
uh someone's I made a tweet about the
[__] ass [__] today I'll get you yeah
and I and I misspelled Barry Wise but I
saw it I was like you know what I don't
respect Barry Wise enough to go back and
change it so oh really spelled like a
berry instead of it's spelled like B
b-e-r-r-y yeah yeah here it is yeah I
retweeted this one yeah because this is
oh my God and again we're going to talk
about this probably the entire day and I
think there's a Matt Walsh thing that
you want to get to eventually yeah yeah
you sent me yesterday or something uh
and it's more [__] lies in the test
and testimony and I believe it was in
Tennessee is that we're just yeah yeah
so um um the non-expert uh Matt Walsh
the the the the the the non-dollar yeah
well come on he said yeah obsessed with
underage children in their children
it just wants to take a peek for a
minute right you know or an hour make
sure a lifetime underage children have
the correct genitalia according to him
right it's really [__] weird stuff
but you say in this tweet here and we'll
start here why not yeah this seems like
a good starting point [__] them uh in
2019 Donald Trump was so triggered my uh
Christy teigen's [__] ass [__] now you
spelled it out how dare you how dare you
look I'm not trying to censor myself
here Tony okay I'm not trying trying to
censor like the like the Republican
Party does right uh I bet you if I made
a book called [__] ass well actually no
it probably would get censored by the
Republicans well I mean you know if you
sold it on your own website like you
know yeah maybe like an e-book you could
say I'm just yeah I'm just trying to
understand if I should make it an adult
book or like a children's book right for
for the children you mean for the ass
[__] like yeah
yeah
so so you go on to say tweet that uh
[__] ass [__] tweet that he wanted
Twitter to remove remove it laugh out
loud
and you go on funny how Elon Musk met
Tybee Barry Weiss and every other
Twitter files journalists and that is
the correct way to use yeah
I conveniently skipped over that part so
what you're claiming I just want to be
sure before we watch this clip what
you're claiming is that Elon Musk Matt
Tybee and Barry Weiss are hypocrites and
they're only acting in a way that would
make sure that it seems like only
Republicans are the ones it seems like
that's what you're suggesting it would
it would it would seem it would seem
that the guy Elon Musk who claims to be
independent though right before the
midterm says make sure to vote for
Republicans to his 100 and I don't know
15 million people I think followers at
the time 118 totally censored by the way
yeah totally censored the platform I'm
using is censoring me oh I only have 150
million people who can sit well actually
it's probably about 30. I mean in real
real real real actual people and so what
happens is they get these Twitter files
that Elon Musk has not read and he has
not vetted and he has not gone through
because there are many times he's like
oh my god did you go see this oh and
then don't you think that was
intentional though yeah I mean he was
like here here finding the stuff you
want to find don't tell me what you're
finding right because I don't want to be
liable and even from the beginning we
know that there were certain things that
Matt taibi and the rest of them could
talk about and couldn't talk about they
signed agreements to what they could
actually divulge outside of the fact
that they died oh well well we went over
this but I'm a mind to understand that
you're saying you're saying that they
could only say certain things and and
had to leave out other certain things to
make sure that that other certain things
were censored is that what you're saying
because it feels like correct it feels
like you're saying Matt taibi uh is a
shill is that a Russian a Russian show
yeah yeah no but that's that is exactly
what I'm saying here Tony because these
people were giving these Twitter files
and they I don't know if they did like a
search and like a like search and find
kind of thing or like search from a
place or whatever they were looking for
they went through uh looking for certain
words keywords probably Hunter Biden
[__] dick
New York Post NY post huge Vlog Trump
huge hog why is it so much bigger than
mine you know stuff like why do I have
these weird feelings when I look at this
picture about a man's private nude photo
that was shared without consent
on the platform
which which let's go to that first
because yeah that Twitter files when
when and because that was the first one
right that was the OG Twitter files the
[__] that they that they act like
was gonna be bombshell stuff and Donald
Trump is still talking about that [__]
he's still talking about it now
so these Republicans
right yeah well and I'll get to that
clip because I think there's a good clip
of Byron Donald's if we we get to that
if we get to it because there's just
mountains of [__] funny [__] to mock
them but in the in the actual first
thrust and I do say thrust on purpose of
the Twitter files
um and that that was just total [__]
is that the government was somehow
censoring this information because
when Biden was running he wasn't the
president yet but when Biden was running
his presidential campaign and people
were posting honor Biden's dick pics
they were reporting these tweets right
is that is that am I getting that right
which anybody can report any tweet right
now you can go on Twitter and you can
report a thousand tweets and any of them
for whatever reason you want to post it
or report it for even if it's not even
close to Breaking that terms of service
quote unquote
so they were just reporting this and he
wasn't the government it was the Biden
campaign
but we find out yesterday we find out
yesterday that it was actually Donald
Trump and the government and Republicans
a republican Winehouse that was actually
using their official capacity to contact
Twitter to tell them to remove a tweet
that they didn't like not that it broke
their term services that they didn't
like because it hurt it hurt Grandpa
poopy pants's feelings and that is just
something we cannot have in the cult the
cult cannot tolerate especially the cult
leader cannot tolerate someone calling
him a [__] ass [__] very thin skin
very thin skin as we know all of these
Republicans these Maga idiots every
single one of them Elon Musk included
Donald Trump especially Jim I don't
report sex crimes Jordan uh Matt I
probably fondled and uh sex trafficked
underage women most definitely Gates oh
you're gonna love Eclipse idiot green
speaking of gates I got a great clip to
play later of uh I think her name is
Nancy mace oh my God it's beautiful oh
god oh no no it's great she's she goes
after gets it's some kind of press thing
it's great if we get to it we'll we'll
get which is also the same woman who
used this to spread her distrust in the
covet vaccine right well not only that
she was like God bless Elon Musk and
Matthew or something yeah yeah get the
[__] out of here so when you see this
you find that oh look they selectively
chose which things to say oh my God this
is the real Scandal and then also being
like Oh no Trump requested that and no
no no no no no no no no no no
and they don't include it but that
they're like Hunter Biden's dick New
York Post Joe Biden's son hell yeah
tabloids you damn right that must be the
truth remember when you used to go to
the supermarket with your mom right I
mean I mean I don't even know if they
had the Tabloid stands anymore because I
don't know they still didn't have
newspaper do they have tablets I mean I
don't really pay attention to the
grocery store and I honestly I honestly
walk past because they're right at the
end right it's like right by the camera
rings and then you got these tabloids
see that's why I don't pay attention
because I don't need the candy so I'm
trying not to ride over there but when
you know like I've seen it ever since I
was a kid and I also and I still wonder
to this day because I know that some
tabloids have been sued for defamation
right but I do wonder how they get away
with so much of that stuff unless
they're like oh
person close to the family right and
you're like who is it like I can't
reveal my source
and so I don't know if that's how they
get around it but I wonder all the time
when I see these tablets I'm like what
the [__] are they talking about right
all right New York Post is just a
glorified Cowboy for crying out loud
yeah I mean it's trash yeah I mean when
the CEO has the last name pecker it's
like
well oh do we have to get into the dick
talk again uh we got Hunter Biden's
laptop
the topic is a little hard okay right
okay well let's
let's watch this clip here that you
posted with the tweet and see see what
they say it's only got 1.1 million views
I feel like it should have more than
that let's give it a few more uh Miss uh
uh naravoli earlier you testified about
a 2019 tweet
um that was about President Trump and I
think it's from uh Miss Teigen what was
the Tweet about
would you like me to give the direct
quote yeah absolutely yeah she was ready
this is a direct quote but Chrissy
Teigen referred to Donald Trump as a
[__] ass [__] okay
Free Speech rightfully so happened after
Miss posted her tweet what did the White
House do what did the Trump White House
do for my understanding the White House
reached out to ask that this tweet be
removed it was my team's job this fell
underneath the policy for abusive
behaviors and we evaluate it underneath
our insults policy at that time up to
three insults were allowed and so it was
our job to determine how many insults
were included within that phrase so Gabe
can you explain to the audience who she
is and what her job would be at Twitter
so she's on the team that worked with uh
with
uh you have wow
yeah Joel Roth who's sitting to her
right and he and we're gonna see him in
some of these clips as well exactly and
they're gonna answer questions some of
the funniest ones come out of gosar
where none of them are able to
understand what he's talking about or
what he's saying but what she was doing
is she used to work on the team that
would that would respond to these these
requests right you would get uh certain
requests that were flagged and they
would go up a certain ladder or tears
just say like okay we need a team to to
to look into this and she was part of
that team that would basically assess
whether or not you know after it got
enough attention if this actually was a
big deal right and if you have the white
house because this is what happened the
White House the White House passed it
off to someone on the team right she
didn't get the email directly she got it
by via another team member another
executive and so basically there was a
request that came in from Donald Trump's
White House in 2019 again when he was
the president of the United States
using the power of the White House and
influence to then say hey Twitter remove
this tweet by Chrissy Teigen a private
citizen
because she was mean to Donald Trump and
then Twitter has to be like
what
I mean
okay fine yeah we'll take a look at it
and we have to determine whether or not
this violates the insults uh What I Hear
What I Hear You saying what I hear you
saying is
exactly what this uh entire committee is
accusing
um Democrats of doing that's what I hear
you saying oh yeah 100 it's almost like
it was all projection in the first place
so let's listen let's listen to the end
of this and we'll go to some more Clips
White House reached out not an agency
but the White House reached out and
request that you remove the the tweet
from my understanding yes okay so I I
want to point out too that the
representative uh talking here he's the
first Gen X Maxwell Frost or gen Z are
you Excuse me yes there are plenty of
guys wax eyes wheez these yeah yeah you
know what the hell I'm talking about
right um from Florida from Florida in
the 10th District he's he is a freshman
uh in Congress and he's doing a bang-up
job and you know why Gabe's inches and I
brought this up before
um because he can read well I mean that
helps yeah a lot I mean he has because
he has maybe a team that actually wants
to work hey there you go he's got
serious people wanting to do serious
work in a serious place like Congress
it's amazing it's amazing when you get
serious about I don't know policy and
governance yeah how how professional you
may look it's also you may not have
experience in that realm right I mean
it's also amazing what happens when you
elect officials who actually know how to
do their homework know how to review the
actual documents that have been
presented not claim 5.1 billion dollars
went to see our CRT training
for an elementary school in Illinois
right like some of these people
are able to do basic math and some of
these people are able to use critical
thinking skills right definitely not a
strong suit for the Republican party but
that is
their thing so when you look at this
you're like oh man I'm I've got I've got
some good good feelings and Faith about
this younger generation gen Z especially
those who are actually sitting and
making laws for us in this country right
Shelley on Facebook says I love Maxwell
Frosty's great I would imagine that that
he is going to be vehemently hated by
the right which is way more exciting I
mean I'm sure he's already hated
right right but I mean like I'm saying
like a hatred like like this other
representative that they [__] they
[__] hate AOC oh yeah listen I don't
agree every single time on every single
policy measure with AOC I'm not quite
you know the fan girl of AOC necessarily
dare you uh well yeah but here's what I
will say the thing that excites me about
AOC more than anything else is that
[__] these real America First Nazis
are terrified of her like absolutely
terrified of her and there's a reason
because she also can read she also is
pretty damn smart yeah and it seems like
she has a professional staff to do I
don't know the serious work in a serious
place like Congress it just it seems
like there's a pattern here
um weird weird I don't know that that's
I don't know that seems a little I don't
know man the fact that they're able to
hire competent people who can read and
do critical have critical thinking and
the ability to say wait hold on we
should look into that more instead of
just taking at face value like I don't
know Republican Congressman would in
terms of believing what Matt taibi and
Barry Weiss and Elon Musk have to say
about these Twitter files it's almost
like
they're actually putting a practice of
questioning
the source and questioning the material
right which is you know they're doing
their own research which is what the
Republicans say do your own research but
they literally just take talking they
don't mean it they mean it though yeah
no they don't mean it all I mean because
you know they take the talking points
verbatim and then when when followed up
or challenged on said talking point they
go or well it's see and then just repeat
the same talking point you're like
you're not you're not adding any
clarification for the same reason why we
saw uh Jim Jordan yesterday stumble
around with his little
boards and stuff just like doesn't that
violate the the First Amendment no no it
doesn't well I think you think it does
well I think I think it does I think it
did so there Nana Junior uh Phillip
Phillip here uh points out from YouTube
he says AOC doesn't have to be perfect
just be AOC you are correct Philip you
are absolutely correct and that's what I
love about her the most is that she just
is AOC I actually think Gabe Sanchez I
actually believe that this moment here
is fundamentally way more important
about what was happening at Twitter
um with Donald Trump then the whole uh
Teagan [__] ass [__] tweet yeah yeah
right that was that was just him being a
[__] ass [__] and complaining that
someone tweeted this about him that had
millions of followers and he got his
diaper in a wad right yeah but this
little exchange here I think goes much
further than Donald Trump trying to use
the White House to intimidate Twitter to
take down a tweet they called him a
[__] ass [__] right I'm gonna say that
at least which by the way which by the
way let's remember that on all these
platforms there are policy especially
Tick Tock and other places these are
public figures Chrissy teigen's a public
figure as well and Donald Trump is but
you don't take that office right
especially uh a high up like you know
the most powerful person in the world
quote unquote uh to
to not be able to take someone's insult
okay right if you want to talk a big
game and be like oh you know uh
I've heard I've you know I've heard
people were like oh they can come and
assassinate me or this or that or they
want to talk some [__] big game
where they're like oh if they come at me
dude I'm [__] coming at them I'm
coming dude you want it you want to see
[__] throw hands you want to see some
fists and it's like okay you can talk a
big game but when somebody sits behind
probably on her phone honestly I haven't
seen the original tweet uh to see where
it came from but I'm sure she was on her
phone and was like he didn't mention me
by name [__] ass [__] and sent tweet
from her phone and then was like all
right I'm doing my own thing I'm gonna
go do my own [__]
and then later on finding out that the
the guy who runs the country
and tries to act super tough and super
Alpha and Super Macho yeah yeah could
not take some tweet that was less than
uh 240 characters or 280 characters
from somebody else that probably hasn't
ever met them in person right but
they're like this person is so mean to
me don't even
I gotta get I'm gonna get my white house
to contact Twitter so they can take down
that tweet like I'm sure the guy I'm
sure the guy was pissing and [__]
his depends diapers ordering Diet Coke
ordering uh and just like eating fast
food in some Frenzy
well you know the thing that really
bothers me about about that is that
this is the president United States and
he is focused on one person tweeting one
thing about him
in the world right this was this was the
guy that was supposed to be working for
us
he was supposed to be working for us the
people we technically on a technicality
elected him to be president not that we
all that the majority of us wanted him
because we didn't he hasn't he hasn't
ever won a race with the majority of
votes ever and he won't but the point is
is that he was in the office and instead
of doing his [__] job like he should
have been doing he was focused on one
because this is a quote tweet is that
what it is is that technically what it
is is it yeah it was a tweet by itself
but it was in response let me see if I
can find it yeah see if you can find it
but but that's the craziest part but
this this little
um this line of questioning here from
AOC and it's it's a minute and 37
seconds
but I think this is way more important
and this goes to the heart
of why Republicans are doing what
they're doing by projecting this watch
Miss navarilli are you familiar with the
account Libs of tick tock
I've heard of it from the news yes
um Mr actually are you familiar that's
not the one that's not the one that's a
good one but that's the libs is it the
one word they're talking about wasting
time
yeah I think I believe this is the one
actually now here here is here's this
one of AOC
never rolly let's talk about something
real
I'd like to show you a tweet posted by
former president Trump about my
colleagues and I on July 14 2019. I just
want to point this out I really
appreciate aoc's [__] of attitude right
like she don't get she has no [__] to
give here does not give a [__]
I mean that microphone's kind of in her
way she's like look I don't need the
microphone for people to hear me that's
and she's pounding the paper she's ready
to go here let's watch it says in part
quote why don't they go back and help
fix the totally broken and
crime-infested places from which they
came then come back and show us how it's
done these places need your help badly
you can't leave fast enough I'm sure
that Nancy Pelosi would be very happy as
quickly to work out free travel
Arrangements a day or two after that uh
Donald Trump publicly uh incited you
know violence at a rally uh targeting
for congresswoman including myself
saying go back to where you came from I
miss not really as I understand it you
were the most senior member of Twitter's
content moderation team or a senior
member of Twitter's content moderation
team when this was posted
um as part of your responsibilities did
you review this tweet
yes it was my team's responsibility to
review these tweets and what did you
conclude my team Ray made the
recommendation that for the first time
we find Donald Trump in violation of
Twitter's policies and use the public
interest interstitial for them so this
this is important because this is the
very first time
that they actually use
uh punishment through the terms of
service to punish Donald Trump's private
Twitter account
um and that that that's why I say this
is way more important and but the result
in which when they punish him what
happens that AOC points out here is the
most important cherry on top of this
Sunday the first time yes and at the
time Twitter's policy included a
specific example when it came to banned
abuse against immigrants as they
specifically included the phrase go back
to your country or go back to where you
came from correct yes that was
specifically included in the content
moderation guidance as an example you
brought now Gabe Sanchez you've got that
[__] before yeah yeah I think I came
from Chicago Illinois actually I
actually got one recently somebody
um I'd have to go back it was a tweet
that I saw last night or a response to a
tweet one person said
uh watch what you say about white people
that was one thing I got and I was like
what does that mean I can't talk about
half me uh and then the other thing was
I saw someone I saw I saw I know it was
on a video
or if it was on a tweet I forget but
somebody was like
I think we should call ice and I'm like
you dumb [__] I'm not I'm not I
I am okay
can you confirm where you're actually
from where you're from can you yeah I
was born in Chicago oh Illinois in
Chicago in the United States of America
I thought you meant like Chicago Mexico
right right you know just uh it's up
there it's north it's north of the right
Mexico right and I mean yeah but it's
kind of isn't it part I don't these
again the reason why the reason why
Twitter has this terms of service is so
that people aren't being harassed and
bullied who I don't know may have
a certain name or I don't know a color
of skin you know these things these
things mattered to Twitter before Elon
took over they see the name and then
they go
and I'm like dude don't have a brain
aneurysm dude just read a little bit
about me right Jesus Christ man but ask
me a question [__] buy me a dinner
first right right if you wanna you know
if you want to get going here well but
Donald Trump this is the first time that
he was found to break the terms of
service listen to what happened to that
terms of service because they had to
cater to this whiny [__] ass [__]
listen this up to the vice president of
trust and safety Del Harvey correct I
did yes and she overrode your assessment
didn't she yes she did
um and something interesting happened
after she overrode your assessment a day
or two later Twitter seemed to have
changed their policies didn't they yes
that Trope go back to where you came
from was removed from the content
moderation guidance as an example so
Twitter changed their own policy after
the president violated it in order to
potentially accommodate his tweet yes
thank you
um
um now here here's what I'll tell you
Gabe Sanchez because here's what I want
here's what I am demanding I'm demanding
right now from Elon Musk transparency I
want I want Elon Musk to have full
transparency of why when how and who was
responsible
and if there was any contact made from
the government because what I want to
know I want to know and I think the
citizens of America want to know rather
Donald Trump and the Trump
Administration weaponized our government
against citizens of this country and
weaponized it against Twitter and their
terms of services I actually believe
that we should have as soon as we take
power in 2024 when we take power and we
take over the government I think what we
should do is have Committee hearing
after Committee hearing after Committee
hearing to get to the bottom of what
America really cares about and what
America cares about Gabe Sanchez is
rather Donald Trump used the government
to bully Twitter to change their terms
of service so he was not in violation of
it I think that's the most important and
it's all [__] well you want actually
I I [__] want to start a committee I
do want to start a committee that looks
into Twitter and right specifically
Donald Trump and I'm going to call it
the [__] ass [__] committee oh that's
great right that's great and it's going
to be looking into all of these
Republicans who reached out to say this
person was to me
why now my president used his I used his
power and his influence as the president
at the time to use the resources at the
White House to contact Twitter bully
bully private citizens bully people who
were not public figures and use the
influence to say hey Twitter you should
remove these policies so that I can
tweet these bigoted xenophobic hateful
things from my Twitter account because
we know we know for sure that there was
no [__] chance no chance that when
this worked its way up the ladder and
was overturned they were like oh well
we're we're just out of nowhere out of
nowhere with no conference whatsoever
whatsoever from the person who would be
yelling and screaming like a pussy-ass
[__] about their account being [__]
dinged there's no way that Twitter
change that terms of service without
receiving any kind of pressure from
Donald Trump and the Trump
Administration right it's nonsense that
is ridiculous to think and the craziest
part is this is all the way back in the
summer of 2019. yep
this is before they got into the the
2020 election cycle yeah I mean you know
he he was a he was a Menace In terms he
would instigate was is always yeah I
know come on but he is uh I mean now he
just does it from his own platform uh by
by truthing re-truthing about how Ron
DeSantis is a pedophile which is like
hey man you do you uh I won't disagree
with you there but also hey it's called
spade a spade here you know right well
you know
um when when your enemies when your
friends become your enemies and uh your
own maybe maybe actually actually I see
here
uh we need to make a t-shirt a [__] ass
[__] T-shirt oh let's do it let's do
we're doing it we're doing doing it
p-a-b p-a-b Let's Do It um we'll we'll
get one we'll get one made up everyone
wants us Surfs Up [__] shirt
too so we'll put those two on the list
Surf's Up [__] and um [__] ass
[__] maybe what we'll do is uh maybe we
should maybe we should make like a a
like committee like you're a Committee
Member like [__] ass [__] Committee
Member yeah that's it that yes boom
write it down make sure you don't lose
that idea now
um what will what I think we'll do also
is we'll come up with a couple different
designs so that you guys can vote on
them and I'll put them over on patreon
or something or maybe we'll put it on
the Twitter account or something like
that so you guys can vote on it and see
which one you want
um we'll figure that out we'll figure
that out [__] ass [__] committee
Committee Member yeah man that's good
that's good oh God damn uh so here is
here's the other moment with the libs of
tick tock um where AOC goes after the
libs of tick tock uh again to point out
AOC beautifully masterly points out that
conservatives weren't being silenced as
a matter of fact Twitter was
and we know this from the Twitter files
itself they were giving special
attention to these accounts they weren't
they weren't giving special attention to
censor them they were giving special
attention to keep them running right is
what they were doing and we know that
from the Twitter files they exposed that
with their screenshots and we can go
back and talk about that but let's
listen to AOC tell it Miss navarilli are
you familiar with the accounts Libs of
tick tock
talk I have heard of it from the news
yes
um Mr Roth are you familiar with this
account
yes ma'am I am
are you aware from that from August 11
to August 16th that account posted false
information about Boston Children's
Hospital claiming that they were
providing hysterectomies
to children
yes I am aware of that and other claims
from the account and are you aware that
this lie was then circulated by other
prominent far-right influencers
yes
and are you aware that all these claims
uh which I have reiterated were false
culminated in a real-life harassment and
ultimately a bomb threat
to the Boston Children's Hospital
yes I am aware and this account is still
on that platform today isn't it
regrettably yes it is
despite inspire
the right-wing incitement of violence
against trans Americans in this tree
because they cannot
let go of this obsession
with fixating violence and inciting
violence against trans and LGBT people
in addition to immigrants in addition to
women of color this is a party that
cannot pick on anyone their own size
and they are trying to co-opt an entire
social media platform and use the power
of this committee and of Congress in
order to pursue a political agenda I
yield back
it's almost like she's pointing out that
the Republicans are using the uh I don't
know what you call it government maybe
would that be a good word yeah the
weaponization yeah the private use of a
another of a platform of a utility
that's that somebody uses to you know
get information and say hey you know
what I actually want to curtail some
news and some mean things said about
some someone specific
and move it off to the side and say hey
maybe we don't show those things or
maybe remove the people that do but hey
let's amplify the people that attack
anyone who is of color a woman who is of
a marginalized Community anyone
basically who isn't white who isn't you
know a man right uh anything like that
they say
as Libs of tick tock right uh they say
oh
we can attack that's our that's our
god-given first amendment right we can
attack these people so that they either
feel threatened they need to move they
unfortunately in this very sad feel like
they have to you know end their life
right these are the this whole bullying
thing
against innocent people who want to
express the way that they are because a
certain group of Republicans don't like
the fact that they're able to do that
is is gross and disgusting and the fact
that Elon Musk and Twitter is now being
used as a uh as a nuke essentially a
nuclear weapon against those groups is
gross it's disgusting it's vile
I'm actually really surprised now that
you're talking about Elon and how he's
weaponizing Twitter
here's the thing here's also the thing
on this one I'll let you speak and I'll
go into this well well because I was
going to say that I am actually
surprised that this tweet still exists
at this point this morning I'm surprised
that he hasn't pulled down this tweet
because they're [__] ass [__]
um now this is the tweet from September
8th 2019 you can see it here
um and it's it's got a lot of activity
for some reason yeah but here here is
here is the actual tweet and we've been
focused on this phrase here [__] ass
[__] but here's the actual full tweet
LOL what a [__] ass [__] tagged
everyone but me and honor Mr President
so basically what she's saying is you
tagged everyone but me because you
didn't want me to see it right you
[__] little [__] yeah is what she's
saying and he is he's a [__] ass [__]
I mean I couldn't think of a three three
word phrase better to describe trumpism
in and of itself let alone yeah but
trumpism in and of itself is [__] like
you know how there's this song [__]
Donald Trump
well that in that isn't that what
started this all John Legend and and
Chrissy posted a video of them [__]
Donald Trump yeah yeah yeah [__] down
they posted that yeah that's how it
started right that's how I don't think
it might have I could have to double
check because because Trump tweeted out
you you're John Legend and your filthy
filthy mouth wife or some [__] like oh
you should smack her I mean that's kind
of what he's saying yeah I mean you know
it's the same person who was like get
that son of a [__] off the field you
know which is uh knock him out I'll pay
your legal fees but yeah I mean like the
I mean the song itself is you know is
from uh you know nipsy hussy uh hustle
and uh Nipsey hustle and oh [__] I'm
blaming on the other artist's name uh
but it's a great one yeah yeah it's
great song and something and something
something that would play
uh I remember going to protest here in
LA
and they would literally just play that
song on repeat up and down like
Hollywood and all around driving as
they're driving and people would stop
and they protest and then they would
like you know on the bullhorn and they
would speak and all the stuff and then
uh they would continue driving and go to
another neighborhood but they would keep
playing the song and then you would also
it wasn't just them uh it wasn't just
the
the speaker is playing it but then
everyone around was like they're doing
different chants but also saying [__]
Donald Trump but when you say there's
not a better three you know three word
phrase I'm like oh [__] Donald Trump is
one right and then also [__] ass [__]
where I'm like somebody I feel like YG
needs to make a follow-up song called
[__] ass [__] and then team up with
John Legend yeah that's it and get
Chrissy Teigen to deliver maybe maybe
the lines of the song let's see if we
can get an email out to him see if they
can get a follow-up
um what's the name of this what's the
song called I think it's called [__]
Donald Trump I think yeah I think it
actually goes by I think it's called
[__] Donald Trump but I think it's
labeled FDT right on most streaming
plans right because right they everyone
hates the word [__] trust me I know this
right from experience I I couldn't tell
you why I know it from everyone hates
the words I was just I like the word
[__] so I was just reading about this
and it it says that so uh Nancy hustle
was wasn't was able to record this in
about an hour
he made this song in about an hour and
it was all inspired by his positive
experience that he had working with
Mexican immigrants in the U.S oh man God
forbid us Mexicans are good people
greatest song song ever some of the
greatest songs ever were written within
a matter of minutes because it just is
supposed to be a song right right listen
to all you people out there when
creative people sit down and their brain
starts to turn for whatever reason maybe
they're maybe they're high maybe maybe
they've had a great experience maybe
they got a lot of adrenaline pumping but
when an idea comes to you and it starts
to take shape in your brain and whatever
median that you're using whether it's a
guitar or a keyboard or a mixer or a pen
and piece of paper where you're writing
or typing or a microphone when you're
just yelling the screen ranting when an
idea comes to you it just it just comes
to you and you can't you can't not but
get it out yeah and so some of the best
songs are probably some of the songs
that had the least resistance uh FDT
[__] Donald Trump I think that's what
you're saying it goes by now
I want to show you a clip because I
don't want to show clips that are all
you know where
Democrats are making fools that are
Republicans I want to show clips where
Republicans are making fools out of
Republicans as well yeah because I think
that's important here and here is Clay
Higgins
making an absolute fool out of himself
and I'll explain because this is only 18
seconds long but listen what he says
about arrest this is this is [__]
Rich Gabe Sanchez
you ladies and gentlemen interfered with
the United States of America 2020
presidential election knowingly and
willingly that's the bad news it's going
to get worse because this is the
investigation part later comes the
arrest part
uh Hey clay Higgins I hate to disappoint
you man but there's been over a thousand
people arrested because of the trying to
attempt to steal the 2020 what the what
the [__] is this guy talking about we we
this is the first the hearing and then
then rest
[__] listen folks
there in in the history books what is
going to be told about Donald Trump is
that thousands quote me thousands of
people went to prison
for this [__] idiot's political
aspirations and not only that but
hundreds and over a thousand are gonna
go to prison because he tried to
overturn the election results in 2020.
that is what the history books are going
to tell clay you [__] bonehead there
have been hundreds of arrests the rest
have been happening for a long time
frankly more Americans want more arrest
of more people who are in who are the
organizers of this right now as we speak
right now there is a trial for seditious
conspiracy going on for the proud boys
who I bet clay Higgins would love to
give fellatio to at any point when he's
in front of a microphone he probably
loves him some proud boys which is kind
of weird but
it's kind of weird to say that out loud
I can't believe they called themselves
the problem boys but anyways that's
another story but here's the thing is
that is that clay Higgins has has such
mind has so mind [__] himself and he
is such in this Q Anon rabbit hole that
he does not know that there has already
been hundreds
of arrest because of someone trying to
overturn the 2020 election it is [__]
mind crazy I mean that's what happens
when you just don't acknowledge it
you're like if I know if I don't see or
or listen to whatever happening then it
never happened right like if I don't
acknowledge the fact that these people
smeared [__] on the walls of the capital
and then got arrested and there's a fair
amount of people and now we're setting
precedent for seditious conspiracy to
overthrow the government if I just don't
listen to any of that then it never
happened right it never existed right
you know it's the whole like if the tree
falls in a force and no one's around to
hear it it's still [__] sedition okay
right well you know they they pretend
um to not to not know the truth a lot
Katie Porter points it out here this is
uh in True Form and fashion with the
Whiteboard uh Katie Porter dunks on
these [__] I think this is
worthy of showing the audience
well I appreciate your Indulgence
chairman Comer but I won't I won't need
it
so today's Hearing gaveled in
at 10 A.M
for nearly six hours
we have been going back and forth about
this supposed suppression of a single
news story
from a single outlet
for a single day so she's pointing out
their link because what they're hyper
focused on is that the link to the New
York Post story
was not able to be seen on Twitter now
give the audience because I think this
is important for them to understand the
mechanics of this like when Twitter
finds out about this link right and
they're like hey we don't know what the
[__] this thing is right and they decide
to to do operations to make sure that no
one can share this until they figure out
what the hell is going on right yeah
which which may or may not make sense
but it's their purview in their private
website to do this so what they would
what would they do to ban because you
could post the link right you could post
it they would prevent they were
preventing uh yeah so you could I
believe I remember you could post it but
there wouldn't there wouldn't allow them
to have the embedding capability so just
show up as a link
um there was also if I remember
correctly on DMs I believe there was
some sort of protocol they put in I
can't remember if they they did not
allow you to share that specific link or
not or if it was also suppressed because
like I don't know if some people use
Twitter DMS and they'll be like hey
here's a video
and that video or let's say or photo
will be scanned by Twitter and Twitter
will deem it safely unsafe are you
saying that Twitter Twitter's looking at
your DMs Twitter's looking well I mean
they're looking at the content you share
and whatever the AI is yeah yeah I mean
well what's left of it let's say uh
because we know that that uh Elon has
completely just he's Intel oh he's so
genius he's such a genius they just like
slice it up and it's no longer there so
smart he's so smart rocket scientist so
basically what Twitter does is they scan
through and just like they you know if
you say idiot or [__] now on Twitter
they're like hey did you mean to say
that some people might find that
offensive right it's not an actual
person sitting there watching it's yeah
but something gets flagged like I've
made video like I made a couple videos
that were I made a video that was a
matrix like red pill blue pill video
that was about taking the vaccine or
ingesting coveted horse paste right and
I think it's because I showed the needle
in my hand right there's just like a
little epidemic needle and I because not
only that but then in another video I
did which was like a covid back alley
dealer who was like oh you want to buy
some Ira back then or you want to buy
this Shady thing or you want to buy
injections of bleach that also showed a
little needle and I'm almost certain
that the reason that those cannot be
embedded with like a preview in a DM to
other people is because
the platform scans it and says oh
there's this thing in here and we don't
want to show that so in other words with
this link what Twitter could do in the
moment is say okay this link it needs to
be detected through the AI so that until
we figure out what the hell it is right
and they did it for a certain period of
time so you just want the audience to be
clear it's a link that these [__]
real America First Nazis are talking
about just one link but listen to what
Katie Porter says Listen to How She lays
out the facts about this link and the
timing because you just heard her say
that the hearing's been a really long
time focused on this one link this one
platform in one day listen
this hearing has been in its length
nearly one quarter of the amount of time
the Twitter users could not share
the lake we are spending almost as much
time
screaming about this as we are this was
ever a problem
look criminal activity is always a
concern
but if if there is Criminal wrongdoing
on Hunter Biden's laptop that is a
matter for the FBI and our law
enforcement agencies today's hearing is
merely an exercise in misinformation and
disinformation a free for all hellscape
that's what now CEO Elon Musk said
Twitter would become if the platform
became a place where anyone could say
anything I love the look on her face
there and anyone can say anything it's
almost like she's directing it towards
her colleagues across crazy it's sad
it's weird it's weird with no
consequences
it is unbelievable to me that I am
quoting Elon Musk but that is how
ridiculous this hearing has become
the oversight committee like Twitter or
any other social media company for that
matter cannot become
a free for all hellscape where anything
goes and there it is there's the
Whiteboard moment free for all hellscape
yeah oh my God she lays it out Mastery
because in all honesty and what they're
not saying what they continue to say
censorship and all this [__] what
they're not saying is that Twitter
eventually let people share the link
yeah yeah it was only for a period of
time and for like one day for like one
day and and they've and they they've
gone into this explanation right this
the the Twitter safety uh and and team
has looked into it and also explained it
and said the reason that we were not
sure about this was because it it hit
all the red flags for something that
would be done by a a foreign entity
right you're trying to uh spread
misinformation Nation or disinformation
about Hunter Biden and say that the
laptop had this again like they've they
have the laptop the FBI has a laptop
Matt Gates has all the contents on a
thumb drive for some weird reason
well maybe he likes uh he likes the
content on it he likes the content yeah
he likes the cocktails of it yeah sure
the cocktails of the uh the hunter Biden
dick pic laptop yeah well why wouldn't
you now I want I want to point out
something else because I'm gonna get to
this um what's her name Nancy is it
Nancy mace Nancy mace yeah we're gonna
get to her but this is in response to
Nancy May saying God bless Elon Trump
since Katie Porter just invoked him and
she's like I have to quote him right now
this is ridiculous but I have code Elon
Musk for you people here but um this is
great this is a great quote
um from something that was just said in
the hearing listen to this man I wanted
to make sure that that's on the record
now I would disassociate myself with her
remarks when she said as did the
gentlewoman from Georgia God bless Elon
Musk uh for me it's God bless my country
God bless my family God bless my friends
Mr Mr musk can take care of himself
and that in a nutshell is the difference
between someone who wants democracy and
someone who is an authoritarian and
loves authoritarianism I don't
understand how even like Don in the
comments because I had to go after Dawn
in the first 30 minutes Don on Facebook
how they don't understand that you want
authoritarianism not democracy you
should just say that you're not a
patriot you don't like the flag you
don't like our country you don't like
our constitution you're supporting
someone who wants to subvert the
Constitution so they can magically make
themselves president of the United
States not only that they're hailing
private citizens billionaires I am so
pissed off about how our society has
made billionaires you know like these
religious figures billionaires are dumb
[__] they were silver spoons
they got fed a silver spoons some of
them are smart you know of Warren
Buffett I'll give them that but most
billionaires are [__] dumb they got
their money from their [__] Mom and
Dad just like your [__] orange
Mussolini Jesus okay so I want to point
that out um but I do want to go to the
Nancy mace but before we go to the Nancy
mace
um footage in the hearing and I know I'm
kind of jumping around off the hearing
here but I want to show you who Nancy
mace is outside of this hearing and then
we'll go to the Q R and stuff that she
says in hearing because this is at some
sort of Press Club that she's speaking
at and she's speaking about Matt Getz
remember that she's talking about Matt
venmo gants listen
we all knew that Matt Gates would never
let the boat get to 18.
[Applause]
I hope that C-SPAN has a buzzer or a
bleep because this [__] is about to get
real okay it only goes downhill from
here
I do have a message from Matt this
evening he really really wanted to be
here tonight but he couldn't find a
babysitter
I mean come on
whoosh I mean listen I love that Donald
Trump is calling Rhonda Santos a [__]
pedophile and I love when this Q Anon
crazy Wackadoo this nut job is is
repeating the [__] that is truth about
Matt Getz and they are using it to
weaponize against it that's what that's
what I've been trying to tell you folks
if we say it enough if we Amplified
enough they'll start saying it on each
other right the craziest part of
yesterday I showed you the picture of
Ronda Santos with his students drinking
beer right yeah woohoo partying with the
with the girls with the young little
girls Miranda Santos was that picture
was exposed by the left-wing radicals
the Marxist the cabal minus touch minus
touch doesn't want to expose that photo
of Rhonda Santos and Trump is re
re-frauding it over on fraud social this
you can't make this [__] up and the
reason why is because we have to be
louder than they are we have to continue
to pound the drum every single day let
me see if I can find what's the
scummiest um because I really don't have
time to play too many of these Nancy
mace videos well what's the scummiest
one that she was um I think she's the
one where she goes through and she's
basically she the only clip that I saw
of Nancy base um when she got in her for
a little grandstanding soapbox moment
she says
uh you know I took the vaccine and that
was fine and then I got asthma from the
second vaccine [__] you did it and
then she went on to say she's like oh
I've got long haul covet from the second
vaccine and now I've got asthma and uh I
wish I never took it and then she was
like thank God for Elon Musk and
what else you say oh
Elon Musk and didn't Marjan Taylor green
say Elon Musk too God bless Margaret
Taylor green went after went after uh
Joel and called him a pedophile
and I was like
which maybe we can play that clip I just
want to call the biggest thing out when
we do but let's play this one this is um
this is Nancy mace's audition to be the
dumbest person in Congress I think I
think that's what this what we're about
to watch let's see
so my first question this morning of
Miss gadding may I ask of you where did
you go to medical school
and this isn't the clip I don't think
I'm sorry I did not go to medical school
that's what I thought why do you think
you or anyone else at Twitter had the
medical expertise to censor a doctor's
expert opinion
our policies regarding covid were
designed to protect individuals we were
seeing you guys censored Harvard
educated doctors Stanford educated
doctors doctors that are educated in the
best places in the world and you silence
those voices whoa whoa wait a second
Nancy mace whoa whoa whoa wait a second
Harvard is and everyone knows this I
don't know if she's got the [__] memo
but Harvard only produces libtards that
is it those Elites no Coastal Elise
they always walk into this why but also
let's remember that their own party has
many people that went to these Coastal
elitist schools one of them is Ted Cruz
another is Josh Hawley only proving only
proving it's easy to stay maybe it may
be hard to get in the acceptance rate
but it's easy to stay there like the
challenging I have friends who went to
Harvard no no it's not it's not hard to
get in these places all you have to do
is be really [__] rich or really
[__] white yeah no no yeah that's for
sure I mean I'm just I'm just saying I
mean if you don't don't do well on your
SATs your act then hey your parents Buy
in addition to the library
that's right we know this we know this
but this yeah but we know that people
who go to Harvard are not that smart I
mean again look at Ted Cruz that [__]
idiot doesn't know how to govern doesn't
have any sort of empathy towards other
people I mean he doesn't even care for
his dog he left his dog snowflake at the
house when he flew to Cancun to go
vacation and then was called out and
then he blamed his kids well that's
because he's Harvard educated and he
knows how to do the Cancun vacation the
best right Nancy mace told us that she
she just said it's a respected the most
respected institutions the most the
smartest and the brightest come from I
mean you know other than the libtard
elites that come from there if you're a
libtard elite that comes from there then
you're not any good yeah you're the
dumbest person just because you
graduated from Stanford MD or the or
right Harvard MD or whatever right the
idea that just because you have those
credentials doesn't make you an actual
person who should be speaking you could
have gone to Harvard Medical School
right to become a veterinarian right but
you could be like oh yeah I went to
Harvard Medical School so I can totally
speak on this stuff absolutely I didn't
actually do the research I'm reviewing
other people's peer-reviewed research
and telling you you what my assessment
is but I've never actually been an
epidemiologist I've never been inside a
lab I've never actually fought viruses
what are those this is like Elon Musk
claiming he [__] invented the EV okay
here's here's the clip I think we're
looking for here's the one chairman the
Twitter fires files were not just about
Hunter Biden's laptop Twitter files make
it apparent Twitter worked overtime to
suppress accurate coveted information Dr
J bhattacharya is a professor of
medicine at Stanford who once tweeted an
article he wrote about natural immunity
thanks to Elon musk's release of the
Twitter files we learned some of his
tweets were tagged with the label of
Trends Blacklist now she invokes Elon
Musk here is the one who released the
Twitter files from what I understand
Elon does not take credit for that he's
just like I just gave the mix yeah he
goes I just came in and also and also
let's let's let's just call attention to
this whole idea of natural immunity
natural immunity is a real thing it does
occur just like we have natural immunity
for the common cold in the flu
however when you have something like a
novel virus right something that no one
has experienced before and your immune
system says what the [__] is going on
and goes into panic mode right and some
people get sick some people are
asymptomatic people react differently
but when you have a novel virus
something that is brand new and you have
a population just in the United States
alone of almost 350 million people
and you expose this virus that goes
through different International hubs on
the coasts
and then spreads to all these other
areas and people don't have health care
because we have a [__] up Health Care
system and we don't have ways to go
through our medical system
natural immunity will kill people until
enough people die that other people have
it and you say okay people have immunity
but the in order to get natural immunity
you have to uh 70 of the population like
70 75 percent of the population has to
be immune to it they have to develop
immunity but in order to get to that 775
percent millions of people have to die
out of a population that is 330 to 350
million people can I give you a dirty
little secret about the pandemic here's
a dirty little secret that a lot of
people who didn't live in rural areas
don't understand
during the pandemic of 2020 and I lived
in I live in Missouri and the governor
shut down the state and he opened it up
as soon as he possibly could their
strategy was natural immunity their
strategy was to kill for people to die
to get to natural immunity as fast as
they possibly could without without
trying to take responsibility for the
consequences of that that is exactly
what Republicans in this country and
Donald Trump wanted
after they realized that the economy was
going to have a really really that
really shitty effect on the on the
economy because of the pandemic and
there was nothing that they could do
about it
but the only thing that they could do
about it was open up our country and I
still hear this stupid [__] from people
who live in my area there have been no
shutdowns no shutdowns
in where I live in Missouri
since May of 2020 folks
damn near three years and there's people
still here bitching I hear it with my
own [__] ears now I have to call it
out when I hear it but I hear my own
[__] ears that they're tired of the
shutdowns there have not been shutdowns
where I live for almost three goddamn
years there was six weeks of shutdowns
because their goal was to use natural
immunity that was the goal was to kill
their constituents
so that way they could get natural
immunity as fast as possible so that
they did not have the positivity rate
kid [__] their citizens [__] the people
get to natural immunity as fast it's a
strategy it's a strategy with novel
viruses that's one of the strategies you
can take
a degree strategy no no it's well I mean
depending on what your goal is if your
goal is to not give a [__] about how
many people die well I mean the party
didn't realize that they were like oops
we're actually killing our constituents
the people that would vote for Donald
Trump and other Republicans in the 2020
election have now gone six feet under
because they decided that they weren't
going to let this lived hard virus that
was born in a Chinese Wuhan lab come
after me
that's the intelligence that we're
working with you know the other you know
the other sentiment that was happening
in rural areas was this look my neighbor
lives at least at least 200 feet away
from me right there's no way that my
neighbor in their house and their yard
is going to give me a virus come on I'm
I mean they're over there I'm over here
it's all those libtard Democrats that
live in the cities you know the ones
that stack like cord would and and they
have to share housing because it's so
[__] expensive and they they live in
small places with a lot now so the
people that are going to get it and
going to die I'm not and besides I'm
tough I'm tough I'm a I'm a Country Boy
A Country Boy Can Survive the old Hank
William Jr song that's the nonsense that
was the [__] but what they didn't
understand
is is it's not about space between
humans on just the majority of the day
that that viruses won't come in contact
they can come in contact at any point
when you are in human contact with
someone that had the virus they didn't
understand that they didn't get it they
don't get it they won't get it and she
doesn't get it and I'm excited gave
Sanchez about mace oh my God I'm excited
that we have not only do we have we have
Lauren bobert and Margaret Taylor green
now we have the third piece of trailer
trash in the in in the trio here mace
let's listen
apparently the views of a Stanford
doctor are disinformation to you people
I along with many Americans there's
plenty Stanford doctors that said the
exact opposite but I have effects from
the vaccine it wasn't the first shot but
it was the second shot that I now
developed asthma that has never gone
away since I had the second shot
um I have Tremors in my left hand and I
have the occasional heart pain that no
doctor can explain and I've had a
battery of tests
I find it extremely alarming Twitter's
unfettered censorship spread into
medical fields and affected millions of
Americans by Dave Sanchez it looks like
the booster is kicking in or something
oh God oh God
this is hilarious so dumb so dumb no you
did not get Tremors no you did not get
asthma no you did not get heart
palpitations or or murmurs that is not
from the vaccine Jesus Christ John says
are you magnetized are you magnetized
that was another stupid thing remember
when they were putting they were putting
coins and keys yeah well they were
putting coins and keys on themselves not
knowing that the metal that coins and
keys are made out of are not magnetic oh
my God [__] bonus let's let's the
same people who thought if you cut open
a [__] n95 mask a SIM card was gonna
come out well oh my God that's the 3G
you gotta get the back yeah no I know I
know you got to get the one that goes
into you the one that Jesus Christ Bill
Gates will be able to control you with
every person that's went to Harvard
which all libtards have went to Harvard
knows that pressing expert opinions from
doctors and censoring those who disagree
with the CDC I have great regrets about
getting the shot because of the health
issues that I now have that I don't
think are ever ever going to go away and
I know that I'm not the only American
who has those kinds of concerns
chairman oh she's such a violent the
thing that I want to know and I'm I'm
look it took me almost three years but I
finally got covered at the end of last
year right and thankfully because the
vaccine it was
in the booster it was uh very minimal
you know
um I felt like [__] but it wasn't it's
only for a few days like maybe less than
a week
there's a key detail that I'm just going
to assume is being left out of here
intentionally she may have gotten the
first shot in the booster or the first
shot in the second shot depending on
which combination she did
but I'm gonna go out on a limb here and
use my deductive reasoning
to think that you and your logic
to think that and and believe that based
on Nancy mace and her position and let's
say that she was running for office or
she was campaigning she had to meet a
lot of people she had to go out shake a
lot of hands she had to do a lot of
events a lot of a lot of close social
interactions with people I'm gonna
assume that Nancy mace got coveted at
some point in the last three years
and
she developed long potentially long-haul
covid but it's not going to be from the
vaccine that you get these things
because that's not how the [__]
vaccine works
but I guarantee that she was probably
the she probably got coveted and she's
dealing with symptoms from getting
covered
where she's like ah you know I have a
shortness of breath totally fine people
develop the breathing asthma whatever uh
you know body aches or soreness or or
brain fog like these are all symptoms of
having coffee they're not coming from
the vaccine they're coming from actually
getting covered when you're actually
exposed to the virus itself and whatever
uh variation permutation modified like
uh uh Evolution variant that it was
along the way
she also could have other uh you know
somebody she probably had other
underlying conditions that she was
unaware of totally true you know Damon
brings up a good point
um uh uh right here probably had
underlying conditions that she was not
aware of the thing is it's not the virus
or it's not it's not the it's not the
vaccine that's that's causing these
people for the same reason the people
who are like somehow keeping their hands
totally still like a surgeon but somehow
their legs are lifting off and having
[__] orgasm spasms like that doesn't
happen that's the real thing
spasms
committee it looked it looked like they
were you know flicking the old Bean or
oh yeah I mean like multiple you know
don't touch me it makes it worse no you
know all these people either taking
videos from other unrelated covid or you
know events and then saying it was
covered or these people were just
completely making stuff up to be like oh
I bet people will believe it was the
vaccine that gave me this [__] Tremor
that's not at all and Nancy mace is no
different it's not the first or the
second vaccine that gave it to her it's
the fact that she [__] got covered
it probably 100 that's exactly what
happened or she's completely [__]
lying and she's trying to prove a point
and say no no trying to say that this is
the impression and censoring and I I got
sick because of this so we should
totally believe this don't accuse any
Republican of lying that is canceling
them you are trying to censor them and
you are trying to censor their opinion
even though it's a lie and you should
know better Gabe Sanchez here's another
great takedown by Conway yesterday we
watched the video of Jim Jordan trying
to trying to get uh Yol to uh admit what
the first amendment is and isn't and he
was like well I think so I think so and
then that uh a representative Connolly
says my my
look what happens when you can't prove
your point with an entire Committee
hearing but this is this is another
moment in Connolly's uh line of question
let's listen it's appropriate for the
president of the United States to direct
or otherwise influence a social media
company to take down its content
I think it's a very slippery slope
Mr Roth
Miss Gatti Mr Baker any evidence that
Joe Biden's ever done that
certainly none that I'm aware of no
I don't recall anything like that I'm
sorry the the that President Biden did
what sir has Joe Biden ever called
Twitter to your knowledge or his White
House and his best to take down content
or urge you to take down content
I don't know the answer to that question
sir
so let's talk about this for just one
second before we go on to this because
Conley makes a good point this is a good
take down here
um and I don't know if you can see where
it's going but if you don't uh God bless
you here's a here's a here's what I'll
tell you is that my guess is Joe Biden
has never actually himself put in a
tweet in Twitter because he probably
does not run a cell phone or apps or
anything like that it's probably not in
his purview and it probably has never
really been part of his purview Gabe
when was when was Twitter in 2008 is
that winning on Twitter seven 2007 when
Twitter started if you rewind back to
2007 and realize who Joe Biden was then
he was about to become the vice
president of the United States right my
guess is Joe Biden has never has never
personally typed in a tweet in his
Twitter account that would be my guess
let alone
let alone get on Twitter and actually
like scroll down the timeline and be
reading tweets about and I almost bet
Joe Biden has never spent more than
three or four seconds on Twitter other
than what someone else has shown him
that was on Twitter like he's never
actively went and looked at Twitter I'm
sure I'm sure he's actually sent a tweet
but you think so I I think between 2007
and 2000 we're talking 15 16 years now
you think you think Joe Biden picked up
a cell phone typed it in and hit tweet
or you think it was just like someone
else typing no I think yeah at least I'm
not I'm not one one tweet in a 16 well
he has written I believe that he has
written a tweet or any well and a tweet
button but I I I I also believe that he
has a whole team that's responsible for
focusing on their specialized task like
he should be focused on running the
country and
so what you're saying is when you have
an important job like um I don't know a
really high up member of the executive
branch like I don't know vice president
or president maybe maybe one of those
two things that you would have less time
to probably write tweets and not only
write tweets but read tweets about you
to know which one's the sensor that you
wouldn't it wouldn't even enter in in
your Universe to make sure to censor
stuff that you don't even know exists
these are what I'm trying to get at is
Joe Biden does not know
99.999999 of criticism that even exists
out there he does not have time because
he's running a country right he's
actually running a country to pay
attention to criticism that he doesn't
even know exists
no no totally and I I completely agree
with that point because the other and it
actually just reminded me of the point
that I want to make earlier is in the
tweet that Chrissy Teigen had when she
says you know LL what a [__] ass [__]
you know like uh you know tagged
everyone but me what an honor Mr
President
show me anywhere in there that she says
Trump right Donald Donald Trump Donald J
Trump or even tags his Twitter account
nowhere in there in the same way that
Gina Carano had to actively search for
people talking [__] about her dumb uh
Terror on the Prairie movie that was
made by uh the daily wire with Ben
Shapiro she had to actively search out
people typing in tear on the Prairie or
Gina Carano he had to actively type in
Mr President right so we can't show it
to him yeah he had to search for himself
well here's probably in a 3am on his
Adderall high what probably happened is
it showed up in his notifications and
you the point I'm trying to make is that
is that Joe Biden does not open the
Twitter app and surf the Twitter app on
a regular basis someone else did someone
else did clearly someone else did but
let's listen
to that well I I'm gonna have to
conclude at least from three of the four
you don't know there's no evidence he's
ever done that but there's plenty of
evidence
Donald J Trump tried to do that
and
um if we're going to have a hearing
about the misuse of social media and the
intrusion of government
in
the content on social media
we've got an environment rich
Target but it's not Joe Biden it's
Donald J Trump and of course we don't
want to talk about that we don't want to
talk about Russian Bots and Russian
Fabrications using fake accounts on
Twitter to a political purpose and it's
not to help elect Democrats
um and we don't want to talk about four
years of Donald Trump manipulating the
truth and trying to manipulate social
media and threaten it uh or directly to
try to shape it by taking down content
because it was critical of him
personally
um and that's what we ought to be
talking about as we move forward not the
subject of today's hearing I yield back
100 by Scott right you think I wish I
wish they would just throw that out
there just yeah they're like and the
contents of today's hearing which is
[__] committee
I just want to bring up uh Caitlin
brought up a good point somebody said
ask Nancy two-faced mace where she and
Republicans went to medical school
disputing Harvard educated doctors on
abortion and gender affirming care
inciting bomb threats at Children's
Hospitals right which is what we played
earlier and I think it's a valid
question that if you're going to make
the point right which which I think is a
valid question on either end to be like
are you professional in this field
but if you're using it to actively hurt
a community right if you're actively
using it to to censor people that if
their advice would actually hurt a
community right like the whole goal
during covert was like Hey keep your
distance wear a mask just
do what you would want other people to
do with you right like if they were sick
you wouldn't want them to get you sick
so keep a distance wear a mask and when
you can if you can get if you feel
comfortable getting the vaccine get the
vaccine
but that of course was too much and so
you had to have Republicans say oh this
was censoring because they were you know
trying to limit the amount of people who
were spreading ignorant or intentional
misinformation about uh the virus itself
and so
I think it's a valid question and so
it's you know in in that same point
which I actually I know that we're over
but it does go into the Matt Walsh point
oh well are we going to show the map no
we can wait till tomorrow Let's do let's
do the Matt Walsh thing tomorrow yeah
it'll be a it'll it's who knows maybe he
finds himself on bonehead of the week
yeah probably
um here's what I'll say about the um
your point that you were making there
about the doctors and Caitlyn's point
about hey if you're gonna have that
standard you should have that standard
everywhere the reason why they don't
do you want to know the reason why
Republicans don't do that there's a
three-word phrase that works really well
uh the reason why they don't is because
they're [__] ass [__] that's just
saying I'm just saying they're [__] ass
[__] it's a thing that happens in the
Republican Party thanks for joining us
today even though we went a little over
I could we have there's like 25 other
clips from this [__] thing and
there's more there's more happening
literally right now right now the overst
that Jim Jordan's committee the
weaponization committee is doing the
same stupid thing so tomorrow and I'm
sure that'll work its way on bonehead so
do not forget to subscribe here on
YouTube the Tony Michaels podcast go to
the community tab you will be able to
vote for bone net of the week later on
this evening or follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod you can vote there for
bonehead of the week as well bone net of
the week every single Friday you vote
you decide who is the bonehead of the
week and we break it down every single
Friday in the second hour of the show
also download every single episode if
you're not what the hell are you doing
how are you living without downloading
every single episode in the audio
version so go download every single
episode of the Tony Michaels podcast
well tomorrow is bound to have a lot
more Clips a lot more boneheads I don't
know how we're gonna fit it all in
we didn't get a we like Katie Porter
said it's like we've been here six hours
a quarter of the time that that link was
down look we've been here two hours and
I didn't get to a quarter of the clips
that we could have played so yeah go out
there search for them share them if you
find them share them and you got it you
gotta take the points because yesterday
was a master class on how to rip these
Punk put punk ass [__] ass [__]
apart how to rip them apart
and expose them for who they are and
tomorrow we'll expose more of them right
here on the Tony Michaels podcast noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch same time same place
tomorrow Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
y's meal Barn hadass Beacon